So let's look at the convolution method.
This is the mathematical formulation of the convolution method.
Some of you may remember the cost correlation method,
you might actually find some similarities.
And we'll compare them side-by-side in a bit for
giving you a sense of how what the differences this would be between the two.
One thing to note in here, is we would denote this by a symbol here.
So now, rather than using the symbol which was this for
cross correlation, we use a star for doing convolutions.
Again, the h kernel and F, and it basically allows you to generate an input,
or output G.
One thing we notice is that basically in how we use cross-correlation,
the filter is flipped in both dimensions.
So first it's flipped bottom to top.
That is, the top row is now at the bottom here.
And of course the other flip is when it's right to left.
And then we can apply cross correlation.
So in essence we would have been able to do cross correlation, we're using this
formulation if you've taken the kernel, and process it to has two flips.
One a flip in the horizontal axis, so
the top row would be switched with the bottom.
And then the second flip where we would actually do a flip from the right to
left, where the right row and the left rows would be swapped.
So that would be a complete flip to generate a new kernel, and
if you applied this kernel in this formulation,
this would become a colon to a cross correlation method.